ahora vamos a sacar la integral definida
desde 2 a 4 de 6 x cuadrada entre x
cúbica de x y tal vez al principio
podría parecer un poco abrumador tengo
esta expresión racional pero si solo
volvemos a escribir esta expresión de
otra manera tal vez podrían ver la
solución ya que así podrían ver esto de
una manera más simple porque esto nos
quedaría igual a la integral definida
desde 2 a 4 de 6 entre x cúbica más x
cuadrada entre x cúbica de x lo único
que estoy haciendo separar este
numerador y dividí cada uno de estos
términos entre x cúbica y esto podría
volver a escribirlo de la siguiente
manera esto es lo mismo que la integral
definida de 2 a 4 de quien bueno primero
tengo 6 x al menos 3 este es el primer
término de ai 6 / x cúbicas lo mismo que
6 x menos 3 y después tengo x cuadrada
entre x kubica y bueno esto va a ser
igual a 1 entre x entonces 1 / x
ahora esto va a ser igual primero
saquemos la anti derivada de las
distintas partes y vamos a evaluar esto
en 4 vamos a evaluarlo también en 2 y
vamos a encontrar las diferencias entre
el anti derivada evaluada en 4 y en 2
ahora cuál es la anti derivada de seis
ex a la menos tres bien aquí una vez más
podemos usar la regla de las potencias
para sacar la anti derivada o lo
contrario a la regla de las potencias en
la derivada así que sabemos que si
estamos sacando la integral de x a la n
de x la anti derivada de esto va a ser x
a la n 1 entre n 1 y si estuviéramos
sacando una integral indefinida
debería haber una c + c y la razón por
la cual no ponemos más ser aquí cuando
evalúan en ambos límites de integración
es que la sexta cancelaría
independientemente de lo que sea que
obtengamos así que en realidad no
pensamos tanto en la c cuando estamos
sacando integrales definidas pero ahora
es momento de aplicar esta misma regla a
6x a la menos 3
entonces esto me va a quedar x a la
menos tres más uno lo cual es excelente
2 y lo vamos a dividir entre menos 2
también y por supuesto no olvidemos este
6 que teníamos al frente entonces esta
es la anti derivada de 6x a la menos 3 y
cuál es la anti derivada de uno entre x
bueno podría estar tentados a usar la
misma idea de que podrían ser tentados a
decir muy bien la anti derivada de
exhala menos 1 eso es lo mismo que bueno
uno entre x y esto va a ser igual a amd
x a la menos uno más uno entre menos uno
más uno pero que es menos uno más uno es
cero así que esto no corresponde a esta
propiedad de aquí pero por suerte para
nosotros hay otra propiedad que vimos
por otro camino cuando obtuvimos la
derivada de la función logaritmo natural
por ello la anti derivada de uno entre x
o de exhala menos uno a veces lo verán
escrito como el logaritmo natural de x +
cm pero prefiero la otra forma de ver lo
que es tomarme el valor absoluto de x
porque aquí puedo evaluar
para valores negativos es decir el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
x y esto es útil ya que esto está
definido para valores negativos no solo
para valores positivos porque el
logaritmo natural de x está simplemente
definido para los valores positivos de x
pero cuando sacas el valor absoluto
ahora podrían ser valores negativos o
positivos de x y funcionan porque la
derivada de esto por supuesto es 1 / x
ahora no es muy relevante aquí ya que
nuestros límites de integración
ambos son positivos pero si ambos
límites de integración fueran negativos
podría seguir haciéndolo recordando que
esto es el logaritmo natural del valor
absoluto de x entonces tengo más el
logaritmo natural del valor absoluto de
x lo pongo así porque no creo que sea un
mal hábito hacerlo recuerda si todo es
positivo entonces simplemente el valor
absoluto de x será x y entonces esto
aquí va a ser igual bueno primero vamos
a evaluar todo en 4 y bueno antes de
evaluar 6 entre menos 2 es lo mismo que
menos 3 y ahora sí vamos a evaluar todo
en 4 lo cual me va a quedar
- 3 / 4 al cuadrado recuerda 4 al menos
2 es lo mismo que en 1 entre 4 al
cuadrado y luego hay que sumarle el
logaritmo natural de y bueno podríamos
decir del valor absoluto de 4 pero el
valor absoluto de 4 es simplemente 4
entonces el logaritmo natural de 4 ya
esto le vamos a restar todo evaluado en
2 si esto lo evaluamos en 2 esto va a
ser igual a menos 3 entre 2 elevado al
cuadrado
recuerda 2 elevado al menos 2 es lo
mismo que uno entre 2 al cuadrado y a
esto le tenemos que sumar el logaritmo
natural de del valor absoluto de 2 que
de nuevo es simplemente 2 entonces que
nos va a dar esto bueno vamos a tratar
de simplificar un poco toda esta
expresión entonces esto es menos 3 entre
16 más el logaritmo natural de 4 y luego
esto de aquí es menos tres entre cuatro
y tenemos es decir lo negativo afuera
así que
tenemos que distribuirlo entonces el
negativo de menos tres cuartos es 34 es
positivo ya eso le vamos a restar el
logaritmo natural de 2 y esto aquí va a
ser igual muy bien esto va a ser igual y
déjeme usar este color neutral porque
ahora tengo vamos a sumar estos dos
términos y no involucrar a logaritmo
natural por ahora busquemos un común
denominador tres cuartos es lo mismo que
si multiplicamos el numerador y el
denominador por 4 esto es 12
dieciseisavos y entonces tenemos menos
13 dieciseisavos más 12 dieciseisavos lo
que nos da 9 dieciseisavos 9
dieciseisavos y luego vamos a tener a
los logaritmos naturales tenemos el
logaritmo natural de 4 menos el
logaritmo natural de 2 entonces podemos
escribir esto como el logaritmo natural
de 4 menos el logaritmo natural de 2 y
podemos recordar una de las propiedades
de los logaritmos para poner que esto es
exactamente lo mismo que él
natural de 4 entre 2 esto sale
directamente de las propiedades de los
logaritmos entonces esto va a ser igual
a logaritmo natural de bueno de 2 así
que ahora si ponemos un redoble de
tambor para dar el resultado final ya
que todo esto va a ser igual a 9 entre
16 más el logaritmo natural de 2 y hemos
terminado